SPEAKER 1: Google Cloud comes
with built-in infrastructure
and tools to help you develop
apps and manage your services.
In this episode, we'll go
beyond login and error reporting
and explore the powers
of tracing, profiling,
and debugging in production.
Stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud Log
tools are great.
And I hope you didn't miss the
previous episodes about Cloud
Logging and error reporting.
But when dealing with
logs, it's easy to get
lost looking for needle
in a haystack, especially
when you're trying to determine
where time is actually
spent when your application is
carrying out a particular task.
Cloud Trace is a
distributed tracing system
to help you with
this exact problem
by collecting latency data
across multiple Google Cloud
products and many
supported languages.
In most cases, Cloud
Trace requires no setup.
The cloud tracing graphical
interface in the console
provides recent
traces, each with URI,
latency, and timestamp,
but also most frequent URIs
and even insights pointing you
to common application problems.
For any given request
URI, a heat map
of request duration through
time is presented, giving you
visual hints about which
specific requests may
need further investigation.
Capturing distributed
traces from your application
used to be a difficult
problem, but we now
make it easy with OpenTelemetry,
previously named OpenCensus,
a project that we
started here at Google.
For any running code
that isn't integrated out
of the box with Cloud
Trace, OpenTelemetry
provides libraries that capture
traces and application metrics
from your applications
either automatically, using
included instrumentation,
or manually, via the API.
Once you've identified
a particular bottleneck
in your application that
is likely to require a code
modification, it's
time to use a profiler.
What's special
about Cloud Profiler
is the little to no
overhead that it introduces
while continuously gathering
CPU and memory allocation
data from your
production applications.
Cloud Profiler then attributes
that information back
to the application
source code, helping
you identify what's
consuming the most resources
and how to fix your
performance issues.
Once collected,
profiling data is
displayed using
flame graphs, which
pack a large amount
of information
into a compact and
readable format.
This is not the time
to go into a course
on troubleshooting your
code, but I would instead
recommend that you interact
with the Cloud Profiler user
interface.
Click on the Top Functions
list, and find out
which are the most
expensive functions,
and then click on one to
enable the focused view.
There may well be
some low-hanging fruit
waiting for you.
Writing code is great,
but potentially,
finding hard to identify
bugs is just as important.
Now, be honest-- how often
have you had to restart
or redeploy your application
just because you added a log
statement for debugging?
I know I have.
Cloud Debugger is
a tool you can use
to inspect the state of
an application at any code
location without stopping or
slowing down the running app.
Since we're talking about
live-running applications here,
there are no actual
breakpoints, but instead
two unique features--
snapshots and logpoints.
With snapshots, you can capture
the call stack and inspect
local variables, all without
stopping or slowing down
the app.
With logpoints, you can
inject logging statements
without the need
to restart the app.
Creating a logpoint a lot
like creating a snapshot.
Simply click on a given
line in your code,
and each logpoint will operate
just as a log statement
that you write into
your code manually.
You can add free text,
reference variables,
and set the conditions
for the log to be saved.
Logpoints are written
to your standard output,
which means that you can use
them with any logging back end.
This is no conventional
debugging tool.
It's one that can
help you troubleshoot
hard-to-reproduce problems.
So I can only strongly
encourage you to look into it.
With Cloud Trace, Profiler,
and Debugger in your tool box,
you now have modern and powerful
tools to diagnose and fix
issues that may arise in your
cloud apps, even in production.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to more
Google Cloud Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]